this is again an eye tracking study the
darker colors are the closer you get to
red is where there's more attention on
the region of interest so what you'll
notice here is there's various attention
so what's really curious to me about
this picture is um my adviser Phil
Zimbardo always taught me to be my own
first subject always so I always run
myself as my first subject and then I
always end up being an outlier and
something completely not instructive for
other people so when I looked at this
study the thing that I fixated on was
the gun and you'll know like nobody's
paying attention as a gun it's really
sort of interesting um
but you'll see differential attention so
what the Conservatives are paying
attention to are the emblems of
authority the patch is about I'm a cop
right like I'm I'm the Law & Order
whereas what liberals are paying
attention to is the person getting the
beat down and to a certain degree and
liberals are also paying attention you I
didn't Circle it but to the the cane
like this is a disabled person right not
a single conservative paid any attention
at all to the cane so there's real
differences in what people are paying
attention to it's not again just an
issue of interpretation it's an issue of
perception why is this important this is
important because it can predict
important political choices that people
make about policy issues so in the image
that I just showed you which is this
same image you can actually look at how
liberals and conservatives respond
differently and then the other thing we
manipulated was the story we told there
was a 30-second narrative so in some of
the narratives we called it a beat down
and some of the other narratives we
called it an arrest and you'll notice
that conservatives don't change at all
how they look at the image based on the
narration but liberals completely change
the way that they think about it when
you call it a beat down versus an arrest
why is this important because different
people respond to different stimuli
differently so in other words some
people are much more visual and some
people are much more auditory here you
see in this particular instance that the
reactivity on that is really the
auditory
Tiffany is liberal in this which is a
different image of a woman looking at a
coffin well where we said that he died
in combat versus he was a looter you'll
see that the difference in perception
changes as a function of somebody being
conservative again these are things that
you can run not just with liberals and
conservatives but with other
categorizations as well one it like when
we run these with men versus women
they're always really funny because the
men never pay attention to the narration
it's all about the it's all about the
image but in these it's it's reactive
based on whether or not people are
liberal and conservative and how they
look at the image similarly in the sex
differences one we had an image you saw
the one with Madonna and Britney Spears
you can see the amount of time they
spend looking at the necklace and the
other one it's a story of a it's a
picture of a soldier holding an injured
child and you can look at differences
here I just want to show you how you can
divide it up by sex differences and that
there's differences in men and women
looking at the child's face versus the
child's body so these aren't just
ideological things you can also look at
sex differences as well although we've
been primarily interested in the
ideological differences again these help
you predict policy preferences so we
have people look at certain images and
then find out you know as people did we
make a mistake sending troops into Iraq
or do you think the US this was done a
little while ago do you think the US can
or will win the war in Iraq and you can
predict people's response to that policy
question based on how much time they
spend looking at particular parts of the
image so if they're spending a lot of
attention looking at the flag you can
see that that predicts their answer to
whether or not they think that the US
made a mistake in entering the war in
Iraq and so on and we've done numerous
ones of these about forty of them and
their end up being pretty consistent so
there are particular categories of
things that people care about and you
can look at this again by liberal or
conservative here I'm just listing
some of the Apes some of the Preferences
of people that are particularly
concerned with protection which on
average tend to be people on the right
of the political spectrum
none of these constellations should
surprise people who for example have
been watching the Republican National
Convention so what does this have to do
with genes there was a report a while
ago liberals you know research is
finding the liberal gene that is beyond
ridiculous right why is it ridiculous
it's ridiculous for several important
reasons first most importantly there is
no such thing right why is there no such
thing why can there never be any such
thing because genes aren't that simple
there are multiple genes there are
multiple pathways these things are
multifactorial
they work in complicated interaction
with environmental factors so you're
never gonna find one single thing that's
gonna help you understand the liberal
gene or the conservative gene these
things are very complex and it's not
just Physiology it's not just genetics
but it's also not just environment they
work together what does that mean it
means that DNA isn't your destiny genes
contribute to these political outcomes
but they're not the only thing that
matters the environmental factors also
matter quite a bit
[Music]
you